cloudflare bot Management on ibmcis and
a detection and response framework for
managed file transfer software all on
this episode of IBM Tech now
what's up y'all my name is Ian and I am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements about
IBM technology
start things off this week IBM and
cloudflare are announcing cloudflare bot
Management on IBM CIS a new offering to
help protect Enterprises from bot
attacks
malicious bot attacks are becoming more
sophisticated and manual mitigations are
becoming more burdensome
bot attacks have the potential to damage
Brands steal sensitive information take
over accounts and negatively impact the
bottom line of any organization
Enterprises running internet-facing
workloads neither Dynamic and adaptive
solution and that's precisely what
cloudflare bot management provides
the offering is designed to help users
better manage Bots by applying a number
of different detection methods
first is enhanced behavioral analysis
which helps organizations Monitor and
respond to abnormal traffic patterns
across critical internet applications to
mitigate potential bot threats in near
real time
second is bot identification through
machine learning using a bot score it
provides a single simplified value to
represent the likelihood of a request
Being Human or a bot
and third is risk mitigation through
fingerprinting cloudflare leverages
fingerprinting from millions of
Diversified internet properties to
accurately classify Bots it does not
however generate or store device
fingerprints which can help to reduce
the risk to user privacy
the bot management feature is available
now for any IBM Cloud internet service
clients using the Enterprise Premiere
plan to learn more check out the link in
the description of this video
next up over the past year hundreds of
organizations have been compromised
through managed file transfer attacks
the mass exploitation of move it and go
anywhere has elevated mfts into a
prominent attack Factor
these Internet connected automated
Services enable the transfer of
sensitive Enterprise data between
parties
so by compromising mfts threat actors
can expedite their attacks immediately
jumping to the data exfiltration stage
IBM security X-Force decided to
investigate they found that all of these
mft tools are largely architected the
same way which means that the approach
to detection and response would
generally be the same so X-Force
recently released an index that includes
a sample of 13 different detection and
response Frameworks for the most common
and exposed mft Solutions
this effort is meant to offload some of
these learnings from Defenders
significantly reducing the time required
for Defenders to stop an attack and
helping to prevent future Mass
exploitation
X-Force also turned to Watson X and
created an easy repeatable process to
assess assets by their attractiveness to
attackers
using one of IBM's Foundation models
they created a proof-of-concept AI
engine that analyzes documentation
forums system data and correlates with
environmental context
this enables security teams to quickly
understand the underlying components of
a solution so that they can develop a
detection and response strategy
this proof of concept is really exciting
because it provides evidence that
Foundation models can Empower Defenders
tremendously and optimize their use of
time
to learn more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now